as much as i was like you know kind of
mocking davide's english i want to be
very clear
i like to be day yeah i know i kind of
like him no he's you're a liar
yes he's awesome
no you know what i like about him dude i
can't help but think he would have said
that to me you and i are actually
business partners
and friday beers oh no way really well
okay jared friend and now business
partner
you are a liar actress you know
guys who are 6'4 and [ __ ] ripped with
um perfect jawline masculine jawline
sick hair they're often considered to be
you know sex pests and uninterested in
deeper relationships but here here is
that stereotype broken with davide
who is so intense about having a
relationship um you know yeah i come
here for the right reason yeah how
quickly he cut her off that was crazy
yeah she was playing games yeah
oh my god she is the new i don't like
her ecken sue yeah at all yeah it's just
a type of person where like the drama
just like lives
it's just part of who they are you know
she just creates it yeah she wants the
that i think that's how she thinks about
interacting with people yeah
it's her model of
yeah affection and stuff yeah yeah she
definitely was trying to you know
gaslight him a little bit oh sure all of
a sudden you care what do you mean i've
always cared i save you from the [ __ ]
i save you from the monkey
without my brother's help i saved you
that dude jay was like
trying to be all
level with me man
is there unfinished business and it was
like a millisecond no i don't give a
[ __ ]
there's nothing between me and her
you have nothing to worry about
he smiles like big as hell and jay's
like oh i think there's also like these
moments in every love island where one
person will switch which partner they
want right yeah like they'll be with the
their person and then all of a sudden
they'll kind of hit it off with the new
person yeah the confrontation will
happen between the old person and you
kind of realize like the new partner
will realize like oh this person didn't
handle this right at all yeah and now
i'm stuck with them yeah the gear is
already turning when he's sitting there
being like oh is there anything left
yeah and the fact i think davide being
like [ __ ] no yeah is him being like oh
like you just seen his eyes like oh [ __ ]
also uh who's to do with gemma luca
yeah what a [ __ ] baby bro we have one
whatever getting baby by that new girl
what and then just be like
yeah dude
don't touch me yes so
sitting beside her just sulking mate
she's got [ __ ] cooties like i swear
she couldn't touch me
you know she must have been like [ __ ]
why did i just pick this loser yeah yeah
just dude i want to be with my drama
yeah gemma definitely has like that rich
person
unspoken entitlement yeah that dude it's
like
that guy might as well have like a shock
collar on
with how much he like comes running back
to her being like i didn't even i didn't
even
nothing it was nothing in here i was
like looking at her [ __ ] kneecaps the
whole time yeah i was making sure there
was no there was absolutely nothing
there yeah ratchet kneecaps by the way
yeah wretched not as good as yours yeah
yeah she's like right
yeah that's fair then
all right come drink my pee
and he gets on his back rides him like a
horse yeah come on babe get on who do
you think could win it at this point
who's like the most
in love right now domi i think
you think so i think domi's been the
most like
coupled-ish him and amber were the most
and he was like very committed to being
like hey like i want to find out
if this is real and then she got voted
off so i feel like domi at this point
has the most um
track record of looking for a
relationship yeah i think ekkan sue is
torched i don't think she can win i also
kind of think like gemma's ex and paige
or whatever
they kind of seem like they're
like hitting it off yeah they're not
really showing them much right now but i
think that's just because they're on the
outskirts like just only hanging with
each other yeah yeah yeah they for some
reason they seem super into each other
they're they're pretty strong
and i think that's uh because they're
both extremely like i think they're very
charismatic and they're both very
genuine yeah them domi the three of them
are very like
extremely likable yeah india is super
cool yeah it is the most like the
chillest most real person yes steph on
that show that's like kind of like the
voice of the audience i feel like yeah
davide i think maybe has a chance but
he'll be like a actor or something i
feel like after this yeah so funny how
hard he's trying to find a wife too yes
like he's said the word wife so many
times it's hilariously because i'm gonna
make it you're my wife now yeah yeah
hilariously aggressive yeah it's so
funny it's like there's been a week like
when they gave him the casting call he's
like
i would like to find a wife
like okay well
yeah yeah like that's kind of the idea
but it's not that set in stone no i i
will find they're like okay
all right man yeah yeah yeah we'll
definitely bring you on the show but
this is psycho
this is just for instagram followers do
you not realize that yeah yeah this is
just an influencer incubator yeah it's
for us to sell t-shirts
you know that right no i will find a
wife oh i will enter
castle the dinosaur i need to find the
my wife i the
princess a pitch
[Laughter]
they're going to introduce some guy in
their name billy like
that my brother always talk about
the what billy the bullet we're
i always get it wrong you are bill you
are the bullet my brother always tell me
about you are here to stop me from
finding the princess i will they i'll
destroy you they should actually have a
girl named peach yeah
join the show that'd be so funny
that would be just so painful it is you
oh
it is you
[Music]
i'm a couple episodes behind but i think
the new girl
um
antigone yeah
uh i feel like she's not
i know who's the who's the other one
danica i feel like she
i feel like danica is
too cool
yeah
like
she's just very
um
and she's very comfortable with herself
so doesn't she like she's not going out
there being like [ __ ] it i'm gonna chat
this guy up and i'm gonna try to just
get in there yeah i think she's way too
resp like she's gonna do one right yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think if you're new you
have to go in there and be a [ __ ] yeah
like jay when he came in immediately
like he dogged out a rugby guy and was
like after it yep and same thing ekkansu
yeah but that's how they like got into
the show yep
i think if you go you got to make a
splash yeah
also is it like it's like three weeks
into the show right
is it three weeks maybe it's episode 18.
so like two and a half castle more
happens oh it's two and a half castle
more happens at four weeks right oh
it doesn't feel like anyone's that solid
right now no
no like they got to be in love by the
half point halfway point of the show so
we can get some drama
you